watching this performance there was a
moment for me it was when Ray Kroc first
saw the mcdonalds and like a light bulb
went off and you were practically as the
character you're effectively salivating
kind of like seeing what it could be yes
he's this guy really thought he saw the
future I think it's possible he saw it
even there than just a lot of them you
know I mean maybe I'm giving them too
much credit but it became part of like
society became a part of a lifestyle it
changed the world absolutely I think
what's interesting about this film is
it's sort of like the mac brothers vs
rey Maurice and Richard McDonald those
are some old school man I don't need a
lot of maurices anymore the two brothers
are like traditionalists they're very
much reluctant to sort of change
anything they're very have a lot of
integrity versus that win win at all
costs kind of mentality how much of each
of them view having you well do you
think that the film is a great study of
human nature in that way and I think we
all have the capacity that's why it's a
fascinating story we can understand well
sure you want to serve your family or
your neighborhood it's the best food you
can but at the same time if somebody
dangles a huge check if you just cut out
two vegetables it's it's certainly worth
considering and and where we come down
on that question determines our
integrity or you know I think we all had
some mix of that one thing that I find
really interesting is how McDonald is
not not only about the burger it's about
the brand and the feeling yeah you may
when you see we stand to get sounds
looks at the building and the lights and
the arches yeah that's an iconic shot
you see that's big and he said bought
the back of me saying they're looking at
it that was big for him McDonald can be
the new American church
and anxious to put on sundays boys
[Music]
you